Speaker 1: This is really, really wacky.
As Tucker told us in the last segment,
New York City Mayor Bill de Blasio did say
to Brazilian president, yeah, your boss,
Ainaro, don't come to New York. If you're not
vaccinated, you got to you got to be vaccinated
to go into places. Don't do it. Don't don't
do it. Balseros spoke yesterday at the UN.
Apparently, he's supposed to keep his mask
on all the time because he's not vaccinated,
as far as we know now. It's also possible he
actually is vaccinated. But this is all his
political posturing. We don't actually know. But
let's assume he's really not vaccinated. I believe
he's supposed to keep his mask on all the time.
He took it off during his U.N. speech. Anyway,
what I absolutely love is that because New York
City has this requirement for vaccination to eat
indoors at restaurants, there are now pictures
of Boston and his entourage standing outside
of a pizza shop eating pizza on the sidewalk
because he's not allowed into restaurants.
And it actually seems like this was a really
good idea because his health minister, who
traveled to the United States with him, has tested
positive. The New York Post reporting on this. I
know The New York Post. Brazil's unvaccinated
president was spotted this weekend eating pizza
on a sidewalk in New York City where tourists
and residents who are unvaccinated for the
virus are barred from eating indoors. BOŞTINARU
is pictured with several other members of his
delegation in an Instagram post Monday by Gilson
Machado Netto, Brazil's minister for tourism.
The photo was captioned, Let's go for pizza with
Coca-Cola. The Brazilian president is the only G20
leader who has not been vaccinated for the virus,
has repeatedly defended his decision, citing his
battle with covid last year. Why take the vaccine
to have antibodies? Isn't that right? My antibody
levels are way up high. Now, as a reminder,
if you are recovered from covid, you should
still get vaccinated. The immunity and antibody
levels are much higher if you get vaccinated.
We talked about that last segment and it
bears repeating, but here is where it gets
really interesting. Brazil's health minister
tests positive for covid in New York City.
Which guy is this in the picture? Is this guy
in the picture? I can't even tell. Is it one
of these? I think is it this guy back over the
shoulder? Look at this. Brazil's health minister,
Marcelo Quiroga, tested positive for covid
hours after accompanying president gyroball
scenario to the UN General Assembly. On Tuesday,
Haraga will remain in New York on quarantine.
The government's communications office said the
minister is doing well. The rest of the delegation
tested negative. Quiroga told CNN Brazil he wore a
mask the entire time he was in the U.N. building.
Bolsa narrow vaccine skeptic defied U.N.
rules that asked all those attending to
be vaccinated. He has bragged about not getting
vaccinated. This is absolutely and utterly insane.
What is good? Well, I guess what we could say
that's good is Bolson is not looking so good
in the polls in Brazil. And it would be a really
great thing to remove this guy in a humiliating
and absolutely embarrassing way. Let's hope that
that happens. And what what a just pathetic guy.
I mean, it really is like Brazilian Trump in
many, many ways. We'll have more coverage of
this on our Instagram. Find us on Instagram
at David Pakman. Show back right after this.